you garbage if you and your dad both
dated strippers who worked at the same
strip club
oh wait that's you now
what a step what's the name of the
establishment
there's only one strip club in buffalo
[Applause]
whoa
relax it's all the same [ __ ] to me
and it's called the downer
the sun that sounds like it's for old
why
people
dad was there this is making sense
oh it's top two top tier all right let
me let me get coming here
yeah this guy oh you're going okay
you're giving the aok
i'm out
i'm having a real hard time all right
this isn't yelp everybody chill the [ __ ]
out
they were like trying to sandwiches
tell tiffy and i said what up
everybody [ __ ] relax we got it did
you guys did you and your father go to
this place for a while together
you just pass in the parking lot dad son
don't forget to get milk no problem
pop wait the strip club was open during
coven i had to put a mask on my wiener
[Laughter]
[Music]
you fell in love with a stripper in a
parking lot
outdoor dining at a strip club yo if
you're getting a lap dance with suntan
lotion on
you're a [ __ ] dirt ball
holy [ __ ] dude
[Music]
well let me ask you a question what are
you determined as a nice setup
holy [ __ ] they got folding chairs over
there
they put the goddamn pole outside look
at that paw
[Applause]
all right hold on all right
so you don't want to eat so so you went
there for lunch
i'll i also have gone to strip clubs for
lunch i believe that as well i'm not
[ __ ] buying this at all
yeah cause there's naked ladies what are
you talking about
you got butthole in your face yeah
the potato salad is actually any rack of
ribs is delicious when a topless broads
bringing them to you
okay so how did so what was the name of
the one you
stated
but she was a stripper at another club
it sounds like
what was the name of the other club
okay
man
i love you this guy knows every strip
club within a 90 mile radius
your dad's a
stripper how you doing bob get out of
here what are you doing here see
anything you like there spencer
all right so yeah i love how you're
flexing on your dad's street stripper
girlfriend
this broadworks brunch you believe that
my girl works friday night 2 a.m prime
time
time
so you and your dad start going
thanksgiving's got to be mad awkward at
airplanes
everyone's got glitter on their face
the lights are all
what do you mean low her
i just picture a bunch of them with nets
like all right
bro you are next level garbage
yeah
there's too many like this there's this
is an onion we're never going to get
into that i [ __ ] genuinely love the
[ __ ] out of you you're 100 trash and i
love it
are you guys that was your dad i'm sorry
you guys still dating
[Music]
he's he's quoting the shift like it's an
all-star game
she was actually pro bowl 1982.
i don't know the i don't know the
dirtbag protocol
he's like there's a code amongst us the
second they start kissing in your mouth
you can't go
you and the other boyfriends are in the
parking lot peeking into the window what
are you doing in here
amber no
what's what's what's the name of your so
this is what's the name of your dad's
girlfriend
[Laughter]
yeah she does
man you're you [ __ ] you're awesome
dude you are [ __ ] awesome yeah
this is that's why give him a round of
applause for the whole [ __ ]
wrap it up for the canadians